are there so tell me bro I grew up South
Central Los Gatos in the budget of fifth
vigor in Weston okay yeah enemy can
lessen your again keep your get oh yeah
what is in the game ha about 11 3 about
11 years old and hold you know am 58 a
58 so back then gangs probably different
than they are now
oh yeah basically more body now because
he wasn't in the guns and stuff back
there more Fierstein yeah it was more
fighting yeah it's all about the hips
yeah the tools just changed for yeah so
I grew up with my grandmother and my
mother grandmother raised me my mother
lived in the back house Hudson
grandmother kids stayed in the front you
know I'm saying have some of the
brothers that up the half-brothers they
moved to Compton
and they read got wild down there who
yes and that's a now it's a gang all to
yourself it's not a blood or [ __ ] but it
started off as a grip dog they start off
as a crib now as they like
they can get it off who they want to get
along with get it all with whoever want
to get it all you know yeah I like it
better like this though with the so
heavy on prison time 20 years or 20
years on installment plan before this
time try some of everything armed
robbery shipping murder Burmese drugs
and what maybe so back when you were kid
and intermediate were there other
options for you or was it my family
for me it was probably like the only
thing to do it was it was the only thing
to do you know I mean yeah you have
those people who whose Mama's is real
real hard on me keep him in the house
and stuff and uh and those dudes who
kind of really messed up and how he does
it but most of the ones I know that that
was kept like that and mine tried to do
to do me like that but I didn't let him
you know I didn't have him I was humus
running with the Wild Bunch at a really
young anyway eleven years old I didn't
have a friend under 12 or their own they
were all 16 18 19 20 yeah yeah I was
that kids you can have that kid that you
can hang around with if he was my age
and I tried to complain with you at your
house and stuff and you could be around
me you could be around me I had to go I
had to go you know I said I could ride
your bike I could be better
so I wanna take any bikes and stuff like
that you know sit just spike will just
be a spike
first of all the loves lemon yourself
armed robbery I'm not one lobby strong
armed robbery I made two dudes give me
their money no 11 years oh yeah and
I didn't get no time for their nothing
you're saying back then I was going to
jail getting out and going to jail
getting out like same day you know I'm
saying Long's mama gonna come get you
and my grandmom always came to get me
you know what I'm saying Sonny I didn't
spend over 24 hours in jail until maybe
about 16 16 years old you know and that
start going to camps lies in prison
finish I can have a GED I have a GED one
time I got out of jail and
I put my age up to 18 and went to chop
for Clearfield Utah and I got my TV yes
I have to have twins I have nothing to
set of twins and it's in an older son I
see my kids sporadically now my son is
in prison my son is in prison he has
about three more years to do something
yeah white slavery or something like
that you know Sanderson there's some
crazy stuff he's a he was a little pimp
and I thought yeah my son's the mud pit
my first thing is a little pin and put
my other two kids there in college and
stuff you know in Senegal South West one
one is in South West and one is in on El
Camino yeah one of them's in El Camino
and stuff yeah I was I was in prison two
different states on parole in two
different states at the same time you're
hosting is crazy
yeah it's crazy they tried to three
strike me California twice
before the law came out already had four
strikes you know what I'm saying before
the law he became to existence how he
struck out yeah so he catched me with
drugs and he talked about giving me the
more time than OJ I was in there with OJ
the bicycle man the pizza man and all
the first people that got 29 to life and
I'm better you know understand and they
told me they're gonna if I get found
guilty they're gonna give me more time
he knows he was going to get I think the
most ljk the guy was 25 years and
there's gonna give me 35 if it found
guilty and it was only for dope anyway I
started selling dope I started selling
dope and I was bored as hell and because
of my boredom I had been already robbing
pimp stuff I started off with him I
didn't like kids too much I didn't like
me to get to the ladies I'm saying that
B no I didn't I didn't like that and I
started robbing pimps and then I my my
talents improved and I started robbing
jewelry stores
I robbed 90 stores never been called for
one never been called from blinded now I
tell you about this girl named peaches
because at the same time I live my life
by the old laws of the Bible you know
what I'm saying I believe I can have my
eyes on the kid what America's saying
what anybody says about it I could have
five wise if I won't do almost like the
state of Utah now you know what I'm
saying they've been doing it but so have
I you know I'm saying even now it's so
have I I have more than one day you know
understand was still sugar peaches she
was something else she was she was from
Harlem crib and another movie and she
aren't all sets didn't really really get
along but in the beginning of our sets
we did get along so I'm from that era
but even in the era that we didn't get
them all I still got along with some
people that I got along with at first
because of my hates I'm older so I can
go back to the beginnings of these hoods
you know and you know the people that do
know me and they would rather kill one
of their own
anything to me you know what I'm saying
because we're that cool we're that tight
so anyway this girl peaches I gave her
so much game
she turned gay honey I started want to
be a man - you know what I'm saying I
gave her some of this game she thought
she was the man - and and she used it in
right now she's probably still used it
up in Hollywood somewhere if I haven't
confronted to her I like you to meet
your heroes there maybe you can see
something that I don't know I never knew
she was gonna turn out that way anyway I
started training her to rob the way I
was trained I was training its first a
getaway driver and I started training
her ass - you know what I'm saying I
showed her on it to keep going you know
I'm saying - keep going tactic is no
matter what made you in if you see a
stop like that they wouldn't get into
the right hand and make that right turn
you see what I'm saying this at the
first available time you know I keep
going you know I'm say if it's clear
move on bust that right when you give it
away from a crime you know and I'm
standing it up I trained I was training
her like that and she became a pretty
good driver you know it's a because I
was a great driver and uh and then slash
banded because I start lobbing by myself
and then I pulled her in and she did she
did three weeks with me hero said she
did she did three lifts with me links a
link is a the hitting of the doing of a
job and she did three with me and uh one
of them I got shot the hell up I got
shot all in my back and in my back one
right here bullet you see bullet holes
elbow elbow right here I got shot I shot
nine times and uh what uh coupling too
late but um anyway pizzas ahead that was
my little heart though at the time but I
was married but so I had her and my
first wife Anita
that's it start anyway anyway peaches
peaches were so many stop I started
showing her how to rob she started going
into places with me
with pistol and oh she becomes like a
gazelle I'm telling you she she would
jump on counter and put everybody down
and even I'm still a lot down boom and
go straight to the case of buster case
open the boot get good money you're
upsetting your money all that girls
something else but uh one time just one
time she saved me right here um I played
pistol she leaped the counter went to
her counter and start hitting and
security was in there that I didn't know
about and he shot me he shot the hell
out he back he shot me on my elbow
strumming around and when I spun around
the bullet was you know the velocity of
the bullet spun me all the way around
and when I came back my gun was pointing
at him so of course I hit him I hit him
three times you told I'm sick the food
felt out boom got up and make to the
back he meant to the back but he went in
the back and I didn't pay him no
attention I hit the counter his so I hit
my count my my um my case you know I'm
saying cuz she was over there hitting
those cases over there I started hitting
my case and the fool came on again boom
boom he dumped on me again B hit me
three times right here you the others
said I fell on into the cake Pam so I
fell out him to the case hit her
I had my girls yell my name is stuff you
know what I'm saying and I turned around
and I started up and at the security
guard he came and he turned around and
ran ran and he went upstairs I guess is
it it was over Julie front but you can
go in the bag in the hand storage it
upstairs because you ran up to steal
your mind up safe cause you ran out of
bullets cuz he had a big ass a 357
Magnum but he had 38 load in and
birdshot cuz some of the birdshot hit me
in the back burner shot shells is a 38
load with the blue plastic tip with a
buckshot in it you know I'm saying he
hit me with that like two times in my
back so I have buckshot all in my back
in really hold him in bullet holes here
from that robbery and so anyway we get
the jewelry and stuff she yelled my name
is she ran over to me and asked me was
online cuz I fell all the way up into
the damn case no said and yeah so we got
up he and she helped me out the store
comes up and I had lost a lot of blood
and stuff sounds kind of weak and stuff
so boom we get in the car pool and get
away driving we driving away I mean we
in a Cadillac all tinted windows and uh
we driving out but the windows wasn't
that dark of a tin and you can see
through it you know what I'm saying we
stopped right in your side to this light
the footage that roadblocks for us all
through downtown Sacramento so maybe
things have to stop here tourney going
here we turned to an underground
apartment stall they had parking
underground parking stall we turned into
that but we stopped I jumped out and she
was like oh baby because I had a bag
full of jury
and I'm gonna have no money at all
because when I was getting mine I got
shot in the bag boom boom boom and I
dropped everything but luckily she had
got a bag of jury voters she didn't know
how much I didn't know how much at the
time but she handed me the bag and she
said one baby you know what I'm saying
and she was gonna stay right there
because if we turned into the robot and
we thought the police seen us but they
did you know so returning the robot so
I'm standing here my arm is throbbing it
feel like I had a heart beating of my
own so I know I had home alarm up I went
into this uh-huh I went into the laundry
mat of the department was down in this
basement area and I was in the basement
I was holding onto this damn wall pipe
overhead and I was like baby pink wrote
me a primo hook so I'm smoking cocaine
news in Ramona's primo is the cocaine
and in a marijuana world up together
member I told you I'm gonna ask my
premium for 30 years 20 years without
ever smoking the pain so this was during
that time I did so and I was pretty more
crazy I was smoking like $1,000 a day I
was someone the richest biggest drug
gonna teams in LA you know what I'm
saying a normal river and
I was holding my hand up and uh over the
pipe my arm must be but it stopped
beating as severe when I held it up over
my head I guess the blood didn't burn up
to insult boom so I'm holding on this
pipe and a girl goes and gets a tie out
of the car and that's my mom Louise
Yellin to be able to the elbow is
bleeding profusely right here I still
have a piece of the bullet in this thing
right here I have arthritis on cold days
it's like if it hurts real bad because I
never went to a doctor because I didn't
know whether you know I killed the guy
or not you know I'm saying this day
still so please the haze no matter but
anyway um I don't think that because he
did get up any ran and upstairs you know
and I ran out it was the person buzz out
and whoever whoever I laid she laid down
when she jumped economy stayed hit the
button hope you do it like please hurry
mute y'all go get and you don't see they
are still holding button so we ran a few
we might not be going all that other
stuff happen when I told you holding a
hand up all day so I'm still hold the
handle over thing oh my hand up for
about thirty minutes like bring my hand
down look at my watch I think it's I
think it's shift change you know I'm
saying for the afternoon would she have
changed so I said you know what I bet
you these roadblocks are down you know
understand my driver is still out in the
car you know he sitting there smoking
smoking crack you know cuz I have tenure
crack and uh he was smoking she was
smoking she's smoking crack - she was
smoking I had smoked me a joint primo
and they smoked a pipe you know so they
smoking it so I come back and get a
carpool I'm getting the car and we drive
Austin was just drive my drive regular
and let's get back to the hood right so
bull we get back to the motel up in the
back she had so many goddamned
I mean she has so many diamonds are
diamonds I said baby she said a little
baby here she said all I want
she wanted a jeep she won the Jeep car
and the buzz say I said ok baby
I think you got that in here with me
have in mind I think you got that in
here I'm gonna give you that ride so I
went to my peoples so now I'm back with
a bag of jewelry but he said when he got
their items in a pan with the bag I hope
the fun porthos air I don't know Magna
jury you know he's at jury well uh
community but you got the other sin now
so now back here deals is so he let me
in you know he listed everything you
know saying he says ok give me an hour
and I'll tell you what it's worth you
know I trust this man with my life so
there's no problem for me leave every
bit of jury that I had with me with him
you know there was no problem at all i
when I get let me win him when I came
back he said you have between 76 and 85
thousand dollars worth of jury I said
what he said yeah he said he said what
do you want I said half with your fair
he said happy percent
man I can't even said I can give you 25%
maneuver long story short he wound up
giving me $35,000 cash you know what I'm
saying he wanna give me 35,000 I can so
so long so I said 35,000 cares okay what
can I do three candidates and I didn't
buy pizzas her Jeep but I bought her
kilogram of coach bud which was very
expensive at the time I think it sold
for like five hundred dollars I think I
paid nine fifteen and seventeen hundred
dollars for her upon the book because
she remembers she said she wanted some
weed and a Jeep
that's so she could start hurting the
business I know what I'm saying
even then I had given her so much game
she's ready to be out on her own and
start her own little business of her
selling we you know what I'm saying she
never sold
but she was fine in the [ __ ]
and I told her you know who she and she
didn't like pips because you're not in
like pimps because I used to rob him see
what I'm saying I mean one time a pimp
told her he just saw her walking to a
gas it who pulled up in the gas station
and then 84 Seville
I had the baddest seveal in all sands of
this swag bag it was the baddest Seville
it was all Gucci outside and inside
interior with Alpine everything when you
turn it on when you start the engine is
it looking like a spaceship green lights
just lit up the night of space oh you're
so tight you know sometime looks there
so anyway peaches this pimp tell peaches
he see her walking in the gas station to
pay for the money when I get out to
start pumping gas at the time I just
wanted to see her response for him when
he told her yeah bro I know you still a
[ __ ] because your walk and make you a
million dollars I used to tell her the
same thing girl you love sex in his hell
no I'm saying you need to quit walking
like that you know but she couldn't she
was just that damn flies he's couldn't
you just head back
all right so anyway she going to bed
yeah so we should come out he's she
looked at me she smirked at him and she
went in to pay for the gas when she came
haha she walked over to his car switched
up to him he turned his hear from one
second she pulled out a hood 30 she
pulled out a 38 revolver and hit the
pool here Wow he loves it [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] you mean hold on
hold money is slow money I make dope
money you know what I'm sick I'm just
hitting the car Syd making the car
laughing I love it come on y'all come on
you know Syd
look I'll see the naboda stuff so uh uh
we get a car boom we roll back to the
motel
I had pizzas and my first wife Anita we
live together you know the three of us
I had a couple more too but there wasn't
white statice of repentance and my first
wife when wife status you know when I'm
saying stuff I live with these two
ladies an apartment on between 104 and
108 the Christian in Inglewood family
prints out mafia neighborhoods you know
what I'm saying but then they they mess
with me and then you also move you know
what I'm saying
which was the enemy to them at the time
also pull the trigger now it's super
criminal and we have elevated ourselves
to a status to where we don't care what
sent you from if you want to get along
with us you can get along with us if you
want to get it all over this you get it
over with us you know what I'm saying we
got that notorious and big you know what
I'm saying and Minnie that's really just
one of my to restore Ron I hit nine of
them you know what I'm saying
I don't talk about all of it I just
wanna tell you that and about peaches'
cuz I still know where did this day you
know what I'm saying
and if I can ever see her again I'm
telling I want you to meet her because
now she's also bisexual type stuff where
I've seen her again where she would
still give me what I want as soon as she
sees me it's on with us you know what
I'm saying as soon as we see each other
it's on I just haven't seen her in a few
years man
but the other times when I was in and
out of prison in out of prison because I
did 20 years in prison only installment
playing on in and out you know when I
see her get its own I want you to meet
her man she's a cool girl man she's
really cool her name is peaches hair if
you ever played with somebody and
sending no of Harlem's
and cobras you know our names that come
up you know what I'm saying thank you so
much